SPEAKER 1: Thank you
also to the organizers.
This is a privilege to be
with such a great group,
and I'd like to learn from
you as well as sharing
some of my own thoughts.
I think this side of
the table represents
the cream of the crop.
These people are the
best of the best.
And so if you're able to
get a manuscript accepted
with either of these presses,
you are in terrific hands.
They will tailor and craft it,
the length, the illustrations,
all of that.
Having an editor to try
to really tighten up
some of the prose is
just a fantastic thing.
I'm going to maybe take the
opposite approach a little bit
and talk about life
for the rest of us
when we're not
quite so fortunate
or we're in a very narrow
field or we're aiming
at a very specific audience.
And that's been my own
personal experience.
I'm an Egyptologist, and
that's not for everybody.
So that's pharaonic history
and hieroglyphs and pyramids
and mummies and
things like that.
In trade publications, of
course, you've seen them.
There are plenty of
coffee table books
about everything you
can imagine-- Cleopatra
and how the pyramids
were built and all
of these sorts of things.
But for scholars coming up,
there are much more narrow
and focused dissertations.
And in my own
experience, I've become
a sort of a hybrid mutant
in the publishing world.
And at the risk of
seeming like the enemy
to my esteemed
colleagues here, I'll
tell you a bit more
about my experience.
One of the things
that fascinates me
about ancient Egypt
is its iconic nature,
its graphical nature,
so the pictorial aspect
of the language and
things like that.
So I've been involved from
the beginning with epigraphy
and drawings and reproductions.
And pictures play almost as
large a part in my publications
as the words do.
So I realized early on--
I think back in the '80s
when the first Macintoshes
were coming out-- I
instantly saw this
wonderful connection
between the ancient Egyptian way
of thinking and this now user
interface graphically-oriented
way of computing.
And so I saw the Macintosh
as this way for someone
like me, a
non-programmer, to get
into the design and the
layout and the word processing
side of things.
And so I spent a tremendous
amount of time realizing no one
was going to pay for my books
and to have them beautifully
designed and edited
and all that,
that I needed to take on
some of those roles myself.
And I did.
So my original thesis,
which was actually
an undergraduate
thesis here and which
was published several years
later in a monograph series
in Germany, I can safely
say I designed it myself.
And it's probably the world's
ugliest academic publication
ever produced, with an
amazing array of fonts
and dot matrix hieroglyphs.
And I'm too embarrassed
to bring it today.
But it's a learning process.
And by force, really, and the
fact that I'm a control freak,
I try to pick up as many of
the pieces of this puzzle
as I could.
So from altering traditional
Times Roman fonts
into transliteration
fonts, you know,
H's with dots under them and T's
and D's with lines under them
so that you could transliterate
hieroglyphs and inscriptions
and things and then
working with computer
hieroglyphic fonts
and typefaces.
And now, of course,
they're a dime a dozen,
and it doesn't matter if
you're on a Mac or a PC,
all of these tools are there.
And from there, it's
learning what dots
per inch means and
Photoshop files
and what is publishable quality
and what is just for use
on the web or the screen.
Same with line art
and drawings, there's
a-- what was the word they used?
Complications, I
think, illustrations.
They certainly do
represent complications,
but by dabbling into
each of these fields
and then moving from
Word to FrameMaker
to QuarkXPress, and
now to Adobe InDesign,
I've been able to take on
enough of these skills, I think,
where I can lay out the
books the way I see fit.
And so that is for those cases
where you're not lucky enough
to have Harvard Press behind
you and wonderful professional
designers there, the more of
those pieces of the puzzle
you can control, even if
you're not doing it yourself,
but at least understand
some of the jargon,
I think that really
helps get a leg up
if you're talking about
a limited monograph
series in academic
press, places where
you're going to have to come
out with the publication subsidy
yourself.
They will take
your book on if you
can fork over the
$40,000 or the $70,000
from somewhere to
get it published,
that certainly helps.
And that means you have to
know what you're dealing with.
How can you figure out
what that Microsoft Word
document shrinks down to in
a typeset laid out document?
How many pages
would it really be?
How many illustrations do you
need, and are they full page?
Do they really need
to be that big?
Or can they be half
page or quarter page?
Do you need color?
And, if so, does it have to
be peppered through the text?
That's a lot more
expensive, because it
means all your
signatures have to go
on a four-color or
a six-color press.
Or can they be bunched
at the end of the book?
So most of the book is
much cheaper to produce,
because it's just
black ink and then just
a section of color
plates, for example.
Does it need to be hardcover or
does it need to be paperback?
Does it need a dust jacket?
These are all the
types of formal specs
that any printer
is going to want
to know if they're going to
move ahead with your project.
So estimating those
types of things
and having a handle
on that is good.
I brought a couple
of examples, and I'll
show you just one simple
benefit of this kind of control.
I did a book on a bunch
of Egyptian tombstones
which are rectangular, and
so because I was controlling
the process, I get
to make the book
like this instead of vertical.
And that's the
kind of thing that
maybe working with
an editor, you
may not have that
kind of freedom.
They're used to doing vertical
books for all kinds of reasons.
And there are good reasons.
This one doesn't fit on
a bookshelf very well.
It sticks out quite a bit.
But that's one of the advantages
of controlling these aspects
of the design process.
So over the years, I got
more involved in this
and produced my own
publications this way,
working with
printers, of course,
obviously, and going
on press myself.
And then expanded a
little bit and started
producing Egyptological
publications
for the Metropolitan
Museum, for Penn,
for Yale, Brown University,
for other places.
And that actually brought in
a decent amount of income,
even though these are not
trade publications they're not
bestsellers, but it
was an interesting sort
of side source of income for
me, which was not insubstantial.
The books themselves
don't make money.
These are probably
money losers, but I'd
suggest at this stage in
your career you're not really
out to make millions
with a trade publication.
You're getting your
new scholarship,
your new research out there.
So in a case like this, there
are 500 copies of this book.
It costs a lot to produce,
sells for about $150.
That's probably beyond your
normal price point, right?
By contrast, when I needed a
break from my dissertation,
I did a children's
book, which was just
the hieroglyphic alphabet book.
And that was picked
up by Scholastic Press
and reprinted as a
paperback for $5.95,
and that sold about 200,000
copies across the country.
So it's quite a change between
these different areas of focus.
And I think you hit
on the right term
with diversity, who
you're aiming at,
what your audience is.
Are you trying to show
your new research?
Focus on the colleagues
in your maybe small field,
or are you trying to
do a trade publication
or go with one of
the big presses?
Those are all key.
So the advantages
for me were feeling
in control of the process, being
able to produce the graphics I
needed, do the layouts I want,
choose the format of the book
and that sort of thing, work
with different printers.
The disadvantage, I would
say, is that all of that
has come out of my
own research time.
So the number of books I have
written and produced personally
would, I feel, be much
larger if, of course,
I hadn't been spending a
lot of that time producing
books for colleagues.
So in a sense, it was
enriching because I
got to know my colleagues, I
got to read their works, which
are in my field and, of course,
I was very interested in them
as well.
But, again, all of
that technology time
comes out of my academic
time and my research time.
So I'd say be aware
of those issues.
What are you writing?
What formats does it have?
What kinds of additional
challenges are you facing?
And then you'll
be better equipped
to choose the publishers
that are interested,
see what kind of subsidies
may or may not be necessary,
and to try to take
the process from there
and then be more in control
of what's happening.
That's not for everyone.
And, as I said, this is a
very strange and quirky sort
of career path that I've
taken, where the design
aspect is so much of it.
But even if you're going
to hand that manuscript off
to someone else, it's good to
know what a designer is then
going to be doing.
And as a final
caution, I'd say keep
track of the entire process.
And going forward, there is the
challenge that books like this
could be a bit of a dinosaur.
And I don't know how much
longer museums and universities
will be wanting to see these
small print run publications
going.
And so think about the
conversion of your book
to other types of reading.
Would you rather
lug this around?
Here.
Here's the thickness comparison.
Would you rather lug this
around or that around?
And so often I see colleagues
work so hard on a book,
send it off, it goes
perhaps to a designer
and then to the press.
And then they
totally lose interest
in the final digital files.
And they're on some designer's
computer in another state,
and no one knows where they are.
And was that really
the final version
when we corrected that
plate or that drawing?
And I think that's
just shameful.
If you can hang onto
the final book files,
if you designed them, or know
where the designer is and try
to get hold of those, there
will be an electronic version
down the road or a
web version or ways
to reach a larger audience that
your perhaps small print run
book couldn't do.
So do try to keep track of that.
I think you'll find
more and more that
will be the way to go as these
kinds of portable devices
pick up steam and get
ever more popular.
That is my contribution.
I'm hoping that's
not too at odds
at what the professional
presses have to contribute.
But I'd welcome your
feedback and questions
for any of the panel.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]